welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Daredevil
season 1 episode 2 cut man and our
Daredevil rewatch series The Road to
Born Again Jessica Clemens and I are
breaking down all 39 episodes of the
three seasons of Netflix's Daredevil
chess is out this week but she'll be
back next week for kingpin's arrival
this week though I'm gonna be guiding
you through a Beat by beat breakdown of
the nordliest hallway scene in superhero
cinematic history we opened on a trail
of blood in an alley leading to a
dumpster while harsh fluorescent lights
buzz and flicker we talked last week how
literally everything in Hell's Kitchen
is dripping with the blood of the
opening credits and those blood stains
are literalized here on the pavement
blood even drips from the dumpster edge
meaning that Matt must have further
injured himself upon getting into this
and those buzzing lights foreshadow the
fluorescent bulbs in the hallway at the
end of the episode Matt is the cut man
of the episode title both in his
physical cut condition and the terms
definition in boxing because a cut man
is the person who treats Fighters wounds
between rounds so they can continue the
fight Matt plays this role for his
father Jack and Claire Temple plays that
role for Matt this is where we first
meet Rosario Dawson's character Claire
Temple and she always brings a steady
hand in these series that makes her a
calming presence whenever she appears
and when Clara inspects Matt there's an
interesting effect where she shines a
flashlight onto his eyes and his
people's do do not dilate tipping her
off to the fact that he is blind now
according to Daredevil showrunner
Stephen tonight they toyed around with
the idea of making her Night Nurse from
the Marvel Comics but at the time Marvel
wasn't really sure if they would use
that character in the future so they
changed her to Claire Temple a more
obscure character from the comics and
they did a sort of composite mashup with
elements of the two characters Matt
stops Claire from dialing 9-1-1 just in
time which is crazy considering it
really is just three numbers he knows
from listening what those numbers will
be and when nine and one begin that
means troubles are coming Matt passes
out and the fight commentary carries us
into a flashback
at this point but now price has turned
the table on him as if the announcers
were commenting on his KO this is a rare
instance of young Matt pre-blindness
making the image of his father's beaten
face one of the few visual memories he
carries with him jack says don't get
blood on you sure in the future Matt's
cut man Claire gets blood on her shirts
this whole neighborhood is dripping in
blood interesting detail I like how
inside the medical kit is God's
interceptic and a deck of playing cards
cards are used by fighters to self-test
for concussions showing us how often
Jack has gotten the hell beaten out of
him so Matt stitches up his dad and the
wound makeup effects looks so real that
we're gonna have to blur it because
YouTube freaks out at realistic skin
punctures I mean this is gonna be a fun
series to cover but Jack makes his son
Swig Scotch set it up this poor Irish
Catholic to go round after round with
foggy at Josie's bar Karen catches foggy
singing The Pirates of Penzance by
Gilbert and Sullivan in the office
foreign
[Music]
this is the opening number of act one of
the show and it paints foggy as a huge
nerd and probable Aaron Sorkin fan
because sorkin's always making
characters sing Gilbert and Sullivan in
every goddamn show you should be out
having a life doing poppers and flapper
dancing I don't know what kids do these
days yeah yeah I'm Josh Lyman so Matt
wakes up in the Camera Pants from the
couch showing Claire's sideways before
riding the shot leaving us the viewer
just as disoriented as Matt is as he
asks where he is but really he is more
worried that he is unmasked Matt won't
give her his name all right I'll call
you Mike Mike yeah a guy who used to
date turns out he was very good at
keeping secrets too this is probably an
odd to Mike Murdock who in the comics is
the fake twin brother identity that Matt
assumes some at transitions from being
regrettably maskless about his black
covering to his youth being tortured by
his eyes covered by White Gauze here in
this hospital room he's flooded in green
light whenever we saw Matt pre-accident
it seems like his world was lit normally
but anytime post accident like in his
youth in these scenes and in his
adulthood the lighting designers go
crazy because all Matt sees is a world
on fire vibrant stained glass that's the
real world where nothing makes sense
this kid suffers from sensory overload
from his enhanced hearing where
heartbeats are the dominant sounds
somewhere it's probably Jen Walters
heartbeat that he's hearing I know it I
know it but Jack calms the Sun by
letting him feel his face like in
episode 1. this is a bonding ritual
between this father and son and now it's
being used to calm down the cut man
young Matt says I can't see which
transitions to adult Matt gasping I
can't breathe his own heartbeat must be
deafening to him here Claire helps Matt
breathe and he explains that the
Russians kidnapped a boy they've been
running a human trafficking ring out of
Hell's Kitchen took over when the
Italians folded up now if we are
reaching to connect this to a possible
parallel MCU history these Russians
could be affiliated with a tracksuit
Mafia because one of the guys in that
hallway he fights later is wearing
tracksuit pants and the Italians could
refer to the man Freddy crime family
whom we saw in the 1940s and Agent
Carter in the same group who was foiled
by Peter Parker in a deleted intro scene
from Spider-Man far from home Matt
explains how the Russians took the kid
to set a trap for him something we never
see it's one of the rare violations of
the show don't tell rule in
screenwriting that actually works
because this is character development
for Matt and Claire and the episode ends
with the ultimate no dialogue so don't
tell anyway making that up despite that
based on this Exposition and this scene
is technically a rematch Matt has had
such a long night all of this
this second half of his night after for
most of us it would totally be over and
Matt's steady breathing has allowed him
to attune his listening to someone in
the building man
how do you know that it's on the third
floor already smells like
premium cigarettes and discount cologne
ah by telling not showing in this
instance the episode traps us within
Claire's fearful point of view so it
makes the idea of this smelly killer
somewhere in the building even creepier
like entered sugar in the motel and No
Country for Old Men and we flash back to
Jack taken a beating in the practice
ring and the bell is so loud for young
Matt who still isn't totally used to his
heightened senses Matt is learning
Braille each grew to six possible dots
so each letter is a combination of those
dots you have to feel for what's not
there as much as what is yeah Matt
Likens this with boxing sensing where a
punch could be going before it's thrown
but it's also a world view that Matt
will take with him like when his dad is
not there he must still feel for someone
who's not there or when a kid who should
be safe in bed isn't there Matt is the
one who senses it Roscoe and silk drop
in Roscoe's Roscoe Sweeney or the fixer
from the comics known for fixing fights
silk is a comic's character of Sammy
silk Jr who's a friend of kingpin's son
who actually organized an assassination
attempt on Fist and out of Daredevil's
identity to the FBI these two set up a
match with creel now we saw Carl Crusher
creel and Agents of Shield where he
played the character the absorbing man a
guy whose skin takes on the property of
anything he touches and in the comics he
gets his power from Loki and he later
Partners up and marries Titania who we
recently saw in She-Hulk but this is the
only episode of Daredevil where Creole
gets mentioned these two [__] say
you're young yet plenty of time to have
more kids
what can I do for you boys and you know
Matt totally heard this shitty comment
from across the room in the background
we actually later cut to Matt's point of
view at one point proving this and since
they pressured Jack into taking the
money for his son Matt's father's death
will be guilt that Matt carries with him
for the rest of his life so back in the
present Matt knows that the fake cop
didn't buy Claire's story so he pulls an
American Psycho and
[Music]
it's such a brutal hit I miss when
Marvel Superheroes could hurt people
like this and Matt can sense someone
watching them young and scared meaning
that Matt can listen to Santino's
heartbeat and know how young he is and
know how scared he is based off that at
Josie's bar foggy calls Matt time off
for everyone get down here yeah foggy
assumes that Matt is getting laid but
he's actually in this moment probably on
top of a corpse dragging him up to a
roof because I know anytime I try to
drag a couch up the stairs I end up
sitting on it pet oh it's just nap time
so Karen talks about how she can't get
the blood off her carpet suffering from
PTSD and the lighting of the scene casts
both her and foggy in red from the neon
of Josie's sign but it's like it's
bullying them back into the bloody
opening credits of Hell's Kitchen but
foggy transforms that anxiety into
something to set Karen's mind at ease
these guys are harmless
Tom Belkin
he's the road captain in the kitchen
hellions he organizes the food drive
every Thanksgiving that's Clint Peterson
okay he is a criminal he's turning it
around we're this close to getting his
kids into Saint Agnes daycare Saint
Agnes orphanage is where Matt goes after
his dad dies it's also where ages of
shields Daisy Johnson grows up Matt
strings up the Russian on the Rooftop by
a water tank and Claire admits she
helped him because at her hospital she's
been hearing stories of a man in Black
Mass saving people so she felt compelled
to help him and Matt says I know you're
afraid
men like this win it's interesting that
Matt discusses his moral reasoning
behind his vigilantism right here
because either this rooftop or one
similar to it is where Matt will be tied
up in season two when he debates Frank
Castle about where that ethical line
really is and today's video is sponsored
by Babel one of the top learning
language apps in the world Babble
specializes in preparing you for
real-life encounters and situations and
new rockstars we've been using Babel for
a while now and it's great Studies have
shown that 15 hours of using Babel is
the equivalent of a semester of college
Spanish and 15 hours in Babel flies by
like nothing you can watch videos listen
to podcasts play games or do sessions
whatever kind of learning mood you're in
Babel's got something that fits the bill
you're learning but it's gamified enough
to be legit fun too I have daily goals
and achievements I can unlock as I learn
the language at this point I've been
using battle long enough that I've
leveled up from the Hello Goodbye please
and thank you stuff to the more
interesting things like cm3 como te
mased
so again get 60 off your subscription
when you click the link in the
description or scan the QR to start
learning with battle today the
transition comes with young Matt reading
this quote there's a price to be paid
for division and isolation democracy
cannot flourish amid hate Justice cannot
take root and mid-range we must descend
from the indifference we must descend
from the apathy we must ascend from the
fear these are the words the Supreme
Court Justice Thurgood Marshall part of
his 1992 Liberty Medical acceptance
speech and clearly Matt took that
message of dissenting from Fear to heart
but what really is the price to be paid
for isolation because this quote does in
a way Inspire Jack to go win the fight
with creel something that he does out of
desperation out of machismo and an
unsolicited hero complex which ends up
leaving his son isolated I think he took
the wrong message away from Marshall's
words Jack shows off his new boxing
uniform which he describes to his son as
red really red foreshadowing Mass future
choice of his own costume and he says
the thing about red
I can't tell how much you're bleeding
yeah who says I'm even gonna get hit
or murdocks I get hit a lot Jack calls
his bookie telling him to put all the
money on him to win by knockout knowing
it'll probably mean his death by the
mafia after making a call notice how
Jack leans back and an Italian flag is
frame behind him some of those Italian
mafiosos whose World he's about to blow
up Jack then calls Matt's mother to look
after him saying I know what I'm asking
now what exactly happened with Matt's
mother is explored later in the series
but in the comics Maggie Murdoch
suffered from postpartum depression that
turned into paranoia and she actually
tries to assault the baby and she ends
up leaving the family to go become a nun
so depending on where exactly Maggie is
in her life again jack is not making the
best choices for his son here drunk
foggy and drunk Karen walk the streets
to kill some time after when you told me
I'm never going home again men are
waiting in the dark corners of this
world to prey on us as he says this they
pass under some red light the bloody
world of Hell's Kitchen saying oh go
ahead you joke want to be Josh Lyman but
these few blocks of Midtown Manhattan
with our failed UCB location I'm gonna
mess you up on the roof Claire is now
messed up in a shy guy look that looks
even scarier than Matt does she's
clearly gotten over her reservations
real fast and helps Matt torture the
Russian try stabbing I'm gonna try
geminal Nerf where is it
going through here right above the eye
you want to go in right under there how
will I know when I find it
we shall tell you and Matt brings the
guy over to the edge and tells him I
need you to know why I'm hurting you
it's not just the boy
enjoy it this convinces the Russian that
he is dealing with a psycho he spills
the location of the kid under the Troika
restaurant and Matt actually drops this
guy in the same dumpster he himself was
found in at the beginning of the episode
is he dead
he'll live yeah this tells us that Matt
wasn't entirely sure when that guy
landed the dumpster if he was gonna be
okay and his mat slowly limps off to
possible death we cross dissolve into
his father and the tunnel before his
fight when he goes through those doors
he's bathing light because he is walking
right into that Afterlife by doing this
and we see this fight from Matt's point
of view as he listens to it on the TV no
images just the sounds and after
knocking out creel in the fifth Jack
rushes back to the locker room for a
quick getaway but he cannot help but
taking the crowd's chanting of his name
sadly these precious seconds probably
helped the mob catch up to him later in
the alley and like the Ring of the bell
in the gym earlier now Matt jumps from
The Sound Of The Gunshot in the street
below and for One Last Time Matt deals
his dad's face ugh heartbreaking he
switches from repeating dad to the more
childlike and innocent daddy pleading
with him and now this is it the most
iconic scene of the whole series a five
and a half minute long take of Mac given
the business to the Russian traffickers
in a hallway right now I'm speeding
through the whole things that you can
see it in all its unbroken glorious
entirety but I'm gonna break it down
here beat by beat because there is so
much good attention to detail in the way
this is directed first off remember Matt
is going into this fight already wrecked
several broken ribs some lacerations
that have only just started been
stitched up and it freaking collapsed
lung but this sequence Begins by smartly
giving us a geography of the hallway
layout where exactly the kid is those
Russians playing cards in the other room
everything Matt has to get through to
get to this kid a Russian brings the kid
his meal and we hear that kid crying for
his daddy just like we've been hearing
Matt do this episode and the steals his
apple and Matt enters arms at his sides
just as he told father Lantern last
episode how his dad would always enter
the ring arms at his sides the cut man
has crossed into the ropes yellow in
green fluorescent light fills the space
and as Matt passes the first room his
head slightly [__] to the side as he
registers everything he can hear about
those inside Matt swings over the door
and goes to work the store swings shut
though allowing the stunt double to swap
in seamlessly and the stump fighter here
is Chris Brewster who also did stunts in
Captain America Winter Soldier we don't
see what goes down at first but the door
breaks open when Matt throws a guy
through it that apple thief marches down
the hallway and Matt able to hear him
approaching through all that fighting
times the throw of a microwave perfectly
so that it hits the guy in the head
think about it Matt threw an appliance
into an empty doorway knowing that a
guy's head would soon be there now the
camera Glides past Matt and one would
think that they could conceal a cut here
but according to Chris Brewster they did
all of this in a true Wonder shooting 12
takes of it so they might have stitched
together some different takes but every
tank you saw they did it all the way
through which you can totally see in
their physical exhaustion as they go
which is why they choreograph a beat
here where Matt is on the ground
catching his breath and the Russians are
regrouping too and then Matt continues
to fight through them one of them
actually comes back behind that and Matt
throws the gun at him and the guy falls
back and knocks the camera a bit they
keep it in because it proves how
authentic this all is it's a small
number of Russians but they keep getting
back up which is more realistic for our
fight they just keep getting more and
more tired as they go that could end it
faster by using one of these guns to
shoot them but he doesn't because he is
a non-lethal killer at least tries to be
but really I think he just doesn't want
a stray bullet to hit the kid and as the
Fight Continues it's interesting how the
knockdown door gives a strong diagonal
element to the scene a springboard for
all these fighters to leap off of and as
the fight enters its final act at one
point Matt leaps from the wall to punch
someone and you can see he's just spent
he has to lean against the wall just to
hold himself up and so now the Russians
are able to grab him and get in some
solid hits they take him back into the
room and again we don't see into that
room but Matt comes back out and does an
impressive acrobatic flip kick and then
punches a guy until his final hook
throws him back into the room where
stuff and Brewster swaps back out with
Charlie Cox who sells this exhaustion to
finish the scene and perhaps my favorite
detail before Matt goes in that kid's
room he raises his mask because he
doesn't want to scare the kid and he
knows that for him being able to sense
his father's face was the only thing
that could calm him down and as he
carries a kid out he steps on the door
which after several minutes of several
ripped dudes leaping off this thing the
door finally now breaks as Matt steps on
it like as he walks away you can see
only now is it snapped in two our cut
man has finally broken down the door of
the crime of Hell's Kitchen ah yes
magnificent thank you so much for
watching episode 2 of our road to Born
Again Daredevil re-watch series both
Jessica and I will be back next week for
episode 3 rabbit in a snowstorm
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and watch my analysis of
Christopher Nolan's Interstellar and you
can support our growing Network by
grabbing something from our merch store
nerdriot.shop subscribe to new rockstars
on YouTube and on all social platforms
you can follow me at eavos and Jessica
and I will see you next week bye
everybody
[Music]
thank you